dude time we don't want anything getting
back to the bride-to-be like this
Wow sucks my brothers getting married
and I have to deliver I know a place you
probably get you a bad idea where the
hell are we don't lose him
whoa you certainly follow
Shh welcome
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we had so first
timers with us tonight what do you call
this murdered gentleman what you want
something while I'm just a day
[Music]
they had me locked out can you get out
girl my girl man something else
to belongs to me
action
Wow socks the browser I mean the dynamic
was kind of there from the beginning as
soon as I met Mike it was just kind of
like oh this is this is the guy this is
the guy who you love but kinda drives
you nuts let's drink to their hot haze
and I are just you know great buds and
he's kind of my rock onset like he is in
the movie keep your pants on and Randy
is just this character that's along for
the ride Cheers I think the dynamic was
really natural it was really organic and
it was interesting to see how easily
that came together and coalesced what
you want something while I'm just the
name
Lili's is not a misunderstood monster
you know it's kind of in the vein of
like Frankenstein or King Kong where
it's a monster that has a code it's more
like a wild animal that you can't tame
it's nice to play a role well you don't
have to be pretty you know it's like
that you just be as nastiness disgusting
as you want what the hell is going on
girl my girl man it's something else
I think this is definitely the most
physically and emotionally demanding
shoot I've ever been on and it's been a
really amazing challenge to see how far
I can push myself gentlemen welcome
thank you so much for coming I'm the
proprietor you can call me Nicks
well Justin Wellborn has been in every
movie that I've made up into this point
and the reason I always cast Justin well
born and this is any good actor is they
bring the missing pages to the script
there are a lot of things to inspire it
the main thing wasn't to curl my
moustache in cartoon why why could you
mess with the wrong gun good moving on
Greg is a complete visionary he's always
pushing the limit to want more which is
challenging for me because I'm the
producer and I sometimes have to scale
them back or say we can't really afford
that we don't have the time or the money
but but part of me as an audience is
like Greg you got it you're really
squeezing blood of this turnip for the
good stuff and in the end like when you
see the final product the blood sweat
tears and snakebites is all worth it
you